what's happening there reject nation
we're gonna watch ourselves three new tv
spots slash trailer ones are behind the
scenes and look another new look for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness movies right around the corner
can't wait can't wait people not at all
what was that so excited got a call
multiverse is breaking through
and probably vibrating the table the
camera sits on
just bad for business
your kids are gonna hate your jokes hey
you already do leave a like if you can
let's see what's in store with whatever
new footage there is to offer
[Music]
doctor strange i always suspected this
day would come
because you always suspected this day
would come i'm ready
it's a good line
oh cool
wait what's happening
whoa
and you're freaking me out for your
stickers i hope the real movie does that
i could use an avenger
it's about time you showed up
on may 6
enter a world
in imax tickets on sale now
sam raimi's dr strange and the
multiverse of madness that is a dream
come true
sam
raymond's i got a call from my agent
saying that kevin feige and the marvel
team were looking for a director
for the new doctor strange movie we
fired the first one
it was really intelligent and
interesting so when that offer came and
i thought this would be a really good
challenge ready to go
and a great return
sam is such a lovely human being and
obviously he's standing in this industry
and this genre in particular is
legendary as it should be
sam has become known for this
terrorizing cinema experience
he's creating as much tension as
possible for the audience just ready for
them to have that jump scare moment
how much slime did they cover people in
ways where we were headed with the
sequel to doctor strange knowing that we
wanted to explore the mind-bending
frightening side of the multiverse yeah
emphasizing horror here's
telling the story was such a gigantic
endeavor and there's a lot of
dimensionalized visuals that we use in
telling that story
we shot it with an eye toward that so i
think it's going to be a very exciting
experience to go to 3d
you open this way between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
right
are they
pushing 3d they sound like they're
pushing 3d i didn't even think about it
but now i want to see it in 3d i've
never really been like i have to see
something in 3d but
damn i mean that first ad
first that was like tripping me i'm like
am i processing this for the time
when i first shot full screen yeah and
then i'm like oh my god it's overlapping
the letterboxes is so bizarre and then
for them to like directly name check it
like and to bring all this stuff to 3d
is really exciting like yeah i guess
they really do want people to go this is
written by michael waldron who was uh
the show runner for the loki series for
heels yeah and i was reading today for
writing this he went back and really
watched like the spider-man films a lot
just to have a better sense of the
understanding of sam raimi's direction
like the original spider-man films that
samurai made he wanted to really know
how to write in his voice do the script
to his strongest suits i think that's
really cool because especially when you
get a behind the scenes like this like
how often do you get a behind the scenes
that are capitalizing on the director's
vision the director for an mcu film it's
so common it's just like it's the martin
luther marvel film it's it's an mcu
movie and who's directing it i'm sure
they'll do an all right job cool and
this really seems like this is sam
raimi's doctor strange movie you kind of
feel that like taiko ytd when it comes
to the thor films now like this is taiko
waititi's thor films this is like
feeling like a director's film again
yeah absolutely and i mean i hope the
movie that's the biggest question mark
about the movie to me now is is how much
of a sam remy movie is this gonna feel
like and i feel like marvel and their
creative committee whatever you want to
call it has like really improved and
shown themselves conscientious over time
in terms of how they keep their massive
continuity in order but also give the
directors their vision and their voice
and i'm really hoping that this could be
not that he needs like a redemption but
like a true return to like you know sam
raimi knocked this big blockbuster movie
out of the park well what i love about
the marketing so far for this film is
unlike with spider-man no way home which
was so heavily emphasized on what cameos
are we going to be getting and what
supportive worlds are going to be
getting that seemed to be the case for
this film at first especially what are
the crazy cameos that seem to be the top
focus now whenever i see this movie
being talked about it's really focused
on the main characters it's really
focused on doctor strange wanda and that
seems to be what the zeitgeist is
focused on as well this is like the
exact effect this movie needs to have
where the cameos whatever they may be
are gonna be the cherry on top because
one is like stealing the show for me in
all of these spots even like that one
line right here of like try not to break
the multiverse steven that delivery on
that line was just so damn perfect i
love it so much this movie's also
getting bad in saudi arabia you guys
here oh yeah that's right multiverse of
gayness multiverse of gayness yes sir
try not to break the gate and stephen
let's keep it head rose
in fact jesus wanted to call me mr
string please call me doctor strange how
gay are they making america chavez the
gayest guest yeah she's just going to be
like walking around putting her tongue
down wanting his throat that's right oh
my gosh her and wanda are going to adopt
billy and tommy together by the end of
it
together
do it marvel first mcu lesbian couple
let's do let's do it the dimensional
visuals look great as much as sam raimi
has emphasized that it was like a lot of
imagery is being pulled directly from
the comics i read the doctor strange
oath run and i thought that was
wonderful and i reckon you see some
semblance here a lot of like house of m
visual image reach even that one shot
that feels very sam raimi-ish this is
the only way it seems to be like the
doctor strange quote this is the only
way that that's not even right am i
saying that right
this is the only is that the line
no my question that seems to be the
quote that i'm getting wrong because i
hear a salad in my mind's ear and it all
just comes down to one this is the way
is mando yes this is the only way that
must mean he's seeing into the future
when he's saying that and that must mean
he's seeing a head yeah possible
outcomes all right guys well dr strange
the multiverse of madness tell me you're
excited tell me what you're most looking
forward to about this film leave your
thoughts down below you can subscribe
click that bell hit that like button and
hey let's do a pic
john tell us about rosa parra's
multiverse oh my god it's so freaking
cool all right on this timeline rosa
parra mom
film critic extraordinaire different
timeline rosa parra homeless vigilante
other timeline
rosapara celebrity chef with a dark
secret
her legs are fake a different uh
timeline rosapara is a firefighter she's
super buff and her name is lance door
other timeline
rosapara runs the real rejects and she
gives hilarious reactions that she does
with herself on a split screen
with another variant of her that's come
over into that multiverse they can
bounce off of each other double rosa
double the pleasure triple the fun
uh hey another timeline of rosapara she
is her own child and her actual child is
her mother and uh hey different rosapar
timeline
uh oh get this
rosa
is like really tiny right and everybody
else is average size and it's fun but
also very dangerous for her to exist in
that way
different timeline rosipara is right in
the shower
[Music]